uh we start with some breaking news
happening on the 15 freeway southbound
Lanes at Flamingo are closed right now
there's been a deadly crash at about
three o'clock we're going to check in
with Nate in just a moment but first
Candace Charles is live at the scene
right now with the latest details
Candace good morning to you
good morning to good morning folks yes
we just got new details from the state
police Highway Patrol they tell us that
a male pedestrian was right here on the
left side of the 15 southbound
Unfortunately they were hit by a black
SUV and bounced into the middle of the
freeway here was hit by a semi truck and
then it was hit by another car of course
this pedestrian died here on the scene
and as you can imagine police are still
investigating what they say is a graphic
scene police say this happened around 3
11 this morning all drivers remain on
the scene and are cooperating at this
time police tell me they do not know why
this male pedestrian was on the highway
take a listen to what the Pio had to say
about this horrific incident
but all I can say is that the highway is
never a place for any pedestrians ever
be on we have vehicles traveling at
minimum 65 miles an hour
um you know ultimately it's going to
have fatal consequences so please never
ever be on the highway if you're a
pedestrian
you know at this time it is undetermined
as you can imagine who this individual
was that was walking on the freeway or
why right now you can see that traffic
has been deterred here on Flamingo to
the eastbound would be also believed to
the westbound off ramps you can see the
traffic right here right now um folks
are really backed up all the way down to
Charleston here on the 15 southbound and
again all Lanes here on the 15
southbound are currently closed again
we're working to learn more details as
the story continues to develop we do
have details for you on your detours for
your morning commute Nate has that
covered so stick with us right here on
air online no social for the latest for
now live from the 15 southbound near
Flamingo Candace Charles 8 News Now
thank you so much for that information
from Nevada State Police Highway Patrol
public information officer Trooper
Ashley welbin it's a difficult situation
for everybody obviously for commuters
but even for the police who have to
handle these situations but for you we
rarely tell you to get off the freeway
but that's exactly what we're telling
you right now because you cannot get
there Southbound 15 has been closed
since three o'clock this morning because
of this fatal auto pedestrian crash just
after three so here's a live look at the
traffic that is already backed up this
is looking to the north so these
headlights are southbounders maybe they
didn't get the message but you cannot
get through you're going to have to get
off at Flamingo that's your only choice
and take a look the backups even extend
all the way to the Spaghetti Bowl stop
on I-15 completely shut down by a fatal
auto pedestrian crash so seriously this
is one of these situations where you're
going to be talking about this
throughout the day if you were on the
freeway I didn't know about it I got
caught in the backups maybe call your
employer say you may be late because
this is going to be there for a while
one of the only other questions we're
trying to get answered is when this may
reopen it's not going to be anytime soon
so if you can if you get stuck you get
off at Spring Mountain you can get off
further back at Sahara you try getting
off at Charleston or you may skip the
South 15 altogether because here we are
the backups all ready to the Spaghetti
Bowl thanks to Candace Charles for being
there at the scene with the information
from the Nevada State Police Highway
Patrol but again for you you should get
off not use the South 15 maybe use the
95 to get wherever you're trying to go